[Applause]
[Music]
i want to be clear
to folks in this region who are thinking
about making
that dangerous trek to the united states
mexico border
do not come do not come
as visual politics viewers you're
probably well aware that relations
between the united states and latin
america have never been
easy they've not always been cordial and
it's not entirely clear which side has
been more reluctant to hold hands with
the other put another way this
relationship has
always been less romantic than the
sylvester stallone movie since the
beginning of the 20th century
washington's only interest in its
southern neighbours had been almost
exclusively to align them with its own
geopolitical and ideological interests
this was reinforced during the 1960s
with the arrival of communism in cuba in
the midst of the cold war since then
washington politicians have
not hesitated to support any dictators
palumerity groups
or general evil-doers who were willing
to bow down
to uncle sam
even so the fact is that the role or
rather the interference of the united
states has gone through different stages
the latest one that
former president donald trump was
perhaps one of the most distant phases
of all and he left statements
like this one when venezuela is free and
cuba is free and nicaragua is free then
this will become the first free
hemisphere in all of human history the
last hour of socialism in our hemisphere
has arrived the days of socialism are
numbered not just in venezuela but in
nicaragua and cuba donald trump
however when it comes to the crunch how
can i say this let's just say
that trump never really showed much
interest in latin america at least not
more than a vegan's interest in a five
pound stake but
hold on a minute because now things have
changed there is a new tenant in the
white house a president with a very
different ideas and experiences and one
who is expected to try and take on the
disputed latin american competition once
again
that's caused us here at visualpolitik
to ask ourselves a few questions
like what changes might the new
administration bring beyond the mexican
issue which is his own distinctive
quirks what are the key
issues on the table here and perhaps the
most important question of all
what about china will latin america once
again become the playing field for a new
global contest to find out listen up
[Music]
and by the way for those of you who want
to know more about latin america don't
miss latin politic our newsletter
dedicated exclusively to this region
i'll leave all the information for you
in the description below
hit the road
[Music]
during the last u.s presidential
election two out of three latinos voted
for joe biden however
that is far from the main reason why
latin america is expected to gain more
importance in u.s foreign policy the
truth is that joe biden is the tenant of
the oval office with the most knowledge
of the region to give you an idea during
his time as barack obama's vice
president alone biden visited the region
no less than
16 times never before has a president or
vice president
visited latin america so many times and
it is reasonable to assume that this is
not merely anecdotal if donald trump
considered the region as something
insignificant a sort of
bottomless pit that only gave him
headaches for biden this is a scenario
in play that he has
first hand knowledge of and for better
or worse this has been evident from the
very beginning for example he appointed
juan sebastian gonzalez of colombian
birth has the new senior director for
the western hemisphere on the national
security council that is the president's
right hand for latin american affairs
but of course the changes were not
limited to one appointment virtually as
soon as they landed at the white house
the new team announced
major changes
[Music]
first the bayonne administration decided
to abandon trump's policy of a second
axis of evil comprising venezuela cuba
and nicaragua this basically means that
the venezuelan or cuban issue will no
longer be
washington's only concern in other words
being part of this common front against
this axis of evil will no longer exempt
disapproving countries from the possible
criticism from the american government
for example this is what happened as
soon as the new secretary of state's
team came to power when they made public
they were closely following the
guatemalan congress attempt to place a
judge accused of obstruction of justice
on the constitutional court or when they
expressed their concern about the
violence against human rights activists
in colombia
secondly it was announced that cuba
would be removed from the list of state
sponsors of terrorism we will look at
this
more closely in detail later and the
third decision quickly taken by the new
government was to agree
to grant temporary protected status to
more than 300
000 venezuelan exiles in other words all
signs indicate that we will see a much
more active
demanding and intrusive administration
in latin american affairs at the local
level
but of course the first two issues the
two star issues on the latin american
agenda of absolutely
every u.s president for several decades
now are none other than immigration and
the war
on drugs so the first question we can
ask ourselves is what exactly is the
biden administration's position on
immigration and drug trafficking well
listen up
a boom of immigration and drug lords
donald trump was one of the most
immigration hostile u.s presidents in
decades
and that is saying something and that's
something that joel biden has indicated
both actively and passively
is going to end of course the
consequence of launching such messaging
can turn out to be exactly
what you don't want 22nd of march the
saturated southern border how the first
migration crisis of the biden era came
to be el pais
the impact of the pandemic in already
very poor countries together with the
new position of the biden administration
on immigration
and some of the measures taken such as
the suspension of the remain in mexico
policy which obliged asylum seekers on
the united states
border to stay in mexican territory
until they have regularized their
situation will have provoked a new
migratory wave 17th of march 2021
we are on pace to encounter more
individuals on the southwest border than
we have in the last 20 years alejandro
mayorkas homeland security secretary
they see him as the migrant president
and so many feel they are going to reach
the united states
andres manuel lopez obrador president of
mexico for example the decision not to
deport unaccompanied minors
has caused them to arrive on mass the
number of unaccompanied minors arriving
in the u.s
sets records nearly 19 000 unaccompanied
migrant children
arrived in the united states after
crossing the mexican border during march
this is the highest monthly figure ever
recorded in the country
france 24. and of course that's when we
start hearing messages
like these ones don't come joe biden
asks migrants the u.s
president urged undocumented immigrants
who are the protagonists of the latest
wave of migration
to stay in their countries dw
and i want to emphasize that the goal of
our work
is to help guatemalans find hope
at home at the same time i want to be
clear
to folks in this region who are thinking
about making
that dangerous trek to the united states
mexico border
do not come do not come
the united states will continue to
enforce our laws
and secure our border
but the question is what concrete plans
does this new administration have in
mind
to deal with this problem and another
important question why are we talking
about
immigration if this is a video about
biden and latin america
well the reason has to do with a new
white house strategy let's say that the
new approach of the us government is
that both immigration and
to a large extent the proliferation of
drug trafficking is essentially related
to the local situation
in the place of origin that is as a
consequence of the lack of opportunities
the absence of security
and the lack of strength of local
institutions to deal with the problems
and the current u.s administration
understands that exactly on these points
that they have to work for example when
we talk about immigration
apart from mexico we have to talk about
what the united states called the
northern
triangle guatemala el salvador and
honduras
these are three of the poorest countries
in latin america countries with very
very serious problems high rates of
violence gangs
massive corruption and even politicians
with direct ties to drug trafficking for
example there's the case of the
president of honduras himself juan
orlando hernandez whom we have spoken
about
several times here on visual politics
[Music]
washington's approach is that living
conditions approve in these countries
then there will be less irregular
immigration and it will also be easier
to control drug trafficking that is why
biden is betting on resuming the
strategy that barack obama launched in
2016 the so-called alliance for
prosperity in the northern triangle a
programme that received 750 million
dollars in 2016 but then
under the trump administration that
amount was reduced year after year even
so the total allocated budget exceeded
two billion dollars between 2016
2020. money that was supposedly used to
finance projects to boost development
and improve local living conditions
well now joe biden has presented a plan
to boost this policy again
with 4 billion dollars over four years
that's one billion per year at the head
of this plan he has placed vice
president kamala harris which is exactly
what obama did with biden during his
presidency
when i was vice president i focused on
providing the help needed to address
these root causes of migration
it helped keep people in their own
countries instead of being forced to
leave
our plan worked joe biden it seems the
problem is that it is not
clear that the program really worked the
idea made sense
but the results were poor during 2019
and 2020 immigration to the united
states has skyrocketed
again and for example in guatemala a
country that has received more than 1.6
billion in usaid over the past 10 years
poverty rates have increased
malnutrition is a real problem and
corruption
is rampant perhaps the problem is that
the plan was poorly thought out for
example it is estimated that the
companies that piloted it kept around
50 percent of the budget for items such
as salaries and bureaucratic expenses
which
is crazy that's at least twice as much
as i charge here at visualpolitik
it's a business the same performers win
contracts over and over again
despite having been poor performers in
the past without showing
any level of impact and without changing
anything carlos ponce professor of
business management at columbia
university we will talk about all of
this
at length in an upcoming video that we
are preparing right now and that we are
sure will not leave you indifferent
so you know don't forget to subscribe to
visualpolitik if you haven't already
done the show and help get me
paid then in the case of columbia which
along with mexico is the epicenter of
the narcotics problem
biden has asked congress to raise annual
aid to fight drug trafficking to 453
million dollars annually an amount
substantially higher than the average of
330 million allocated by trump during
his last three budgets it's a funding
policy that fits in with the more
interventionist vision that the new
white house seems to support in its
neighboring continent
but of course that's not all
dreams of caracas and havana
the policy towards cuba is always one of
the most controversial and politically
costly of any us diplomacy don't forget
we only have to look back at the last
presidential elections of 2020 when the
cuban minority in florida turned its
back on the current president and
overwhelmingly favored trump and they
did so because biden is willing to
resume the policy of the taunt that was
once implemented by barack obama and
came to be known as baseball
diplomacy however it seems that biden
learned his lesson when obama reached
out to the castro regime for change and
almost got his hand bitten off so it
seems that the position will be rather
passive
that is that it will need to be havana
that makes the first move and actively
demonstrate that they are willing to
initiate a certain political
and economic transition still one thing
the white house certainly does want
is to leave the door open
biden's team is determined to reverse
the trump administration's inclusion of
cuba on the list of terrorist-sponsoring
countries in its last days of
office it is also assumed that they will
stop the implementation of the helm's
burton act whose title iii allows u.s
citizens to sue
international companies that use or
benefit from properties confiscated by
fidel castro's regime this is a law
which has been suspended by
all presidents since 1996 for which
trump decided to reactivate
in 2019 in addition given the poor state
of the cuban economy and in order to
promote openness
biden's team intends to lift the
existing limits on the re-admittances
and travel to the island
and with respect to venezuela it's
pretty much the same story let them be
the ones to make the first move
but having said that beyond the
increasingly weakened cuban venezuelan
bloc
and in addition to the central american
policy there is another issue of great
concern in washington nothing less than
the fear of chinese influence
[Music]
the conquest of the east
if there is one issue that has been
causing alarm bells to ring in
washington lately it is precisely that
of china's influence on the rest of the
world it does not matter whether we're
talking about the pacific
africa europe or latin america and the
truth is that in recent years
chinese influence on this region has
been on the rise china literally
devours the region's raw materials and
has invested heavily in sectors such as
energy highways and ports
and that seems to be what biden now
wants to counteract
biden's strategy will be to offer
alternative financing for critical
infrastructure sectors including key
areas
such as telecommunications benjamin
gedan director of the wilson center's
latin america program just a moment
however because the most important
move to counter china's growing
influence in the region and at the same
time support the country's closest to
the united states would be none other
than the return to the tpp
now known as the cp tpp this is the most
advanced trans-pacific free trade
agreement to which as we've already
covered in other videos
even the united kingdom has asked to
join and that is exactly what is now
being considered
in washington rejoining this trade
agreement would have two direct
consequences
a boost to the pacific alliance whose
member are part of this agreement and
closer ties between the united states
and latin america it would also put an
end to one of the more characteristic
policies of the trump era
trade protectionism and there you have
it these are the main issues on joe
biden's latin american agenda and
having reached this point here's a
question for you what do you think the
biden administration will mean for latin
america what influence
will it have leave your answer in the
comments below and if you found this
video interesting and of course you did
don't forget to like and subscribe to
visualpolitik thanks very much for
watching
i'll see you next time